Yea now its just
people come in on any random day
whether a earth quake had happened or not
just got a lot of upper respiratory secretions now
you see quite liver failure
from some kind of hepatitis I think
yea the stuff we have been doing the last few nights, people would have died if we didn't take care of it.
it just regular medical
stuff people can get anytime
like the typhoid intestinal perpheration or appendicitis
0:00:33.010,0:00:33.990
he had a
appendicitis that
had ruptured
and so like in the states
someone like him would have been operated on a week ago
and it ruptured and he had a lot of contamination
in his abdomen and he he will do fine
definitely got
a bigger surgery than he would have
had in the states
you want to
go over to the ed
see if there is anything happening
that group said they were coming tonight, right?
yes, we sort of make it up as we go along
it's harder and have a system like that to say who is going to work
that work which shift
people come and go every day
and they're different groups all staying in different places
it ends up working ok
but there some challenges for sure
it's just sort of go with the flow and help with whatever needs to be helped with
when did he eat poison?
so the
population mentally is pretty upbeat
young people with amputations and they are totally
joking and laughing
the whole
infrastructure of the
country and government though seems
less than ideal to deal
Aphrotite
we're so happy to see you
your life saver